a lot to talk about what's been going on
since last time we spoke the republican
national convention was last week
and besides the fireworks one of the
most exciting things was seeing
all of the republican party's rising
stars
yeah these are usually freshman members
of congress or
other new faces who will represent the
future of the republican party
so just to review let's take a look
forward
at some of the rnc's rising stars
first up there's alabama state senator
arch kimball
the first american to legally marry a
hollow point
bullet yeah i understand they're quite
happy
the derbits and el paso family
volunteering to be
a section of trump's new border wall god
bless them
kiriya ouchbaum a graffiti artist who
paints
blue eyes onto statues of jesus she's
doing it everywhere it's
fantastic work she's doing there's tj
and aj
eight-year-old identical twin brothers
who both look exactly like
mike pence and finally bartholomew jr
the fetus that's already born again
all right those are the rnc rising stars